Game of Thrones is over now how do you
feel about it there's so many people
like myself I'm a huge fan I know Andy's
a huge fan it's tough for us for the
show to be done what's it like for you
this was your life for years yeah it's
my whole adolescence ten years it's it's
okay I haven't watched the last episode
the last two episodes because you don't
watch them no it's too emotional for me
yeah but I saw um Dan Weiss last night
the creator yeah one of the creators and
and I saw him and I just like broke down
into tears and I was like it could be
over right right it is well you never
know you never know I mean your
character can I hate to be a spoiler for
you because you're the only one here who
hasn't seen it yeah there's other
adventures you could have you never know
I know but it would just be more trauma
and abuse and there's an abusive
relationship that show yeah you need to
get out you know it must be tough I
experienced his first time firsthand
when I was up where you were where you
guys were shooting about a year ago and
I saw you hanging out with the cast and
I noticed that you and Maisie Williams
are clearly it's no act you're like best
friends you were hanging out together
the whole party that I was at you two
were hanging out yeah
that's so that's a fun night it was a
really fun night yeah yeah
it was and then I couldn't believe that
Hodor was the DJ at this party yeah he
really was he was that got a laugh Hodor
was busy he's he like goes around on
tour and it's cooled I think it's called
rave of Thrones well you got a cash-in
why you can't make that money honey
so but it's funny I was looking at this
this was a party that was a sort of the
wrap party and I got to be there as well
because I'm such a central part of the
show and and and a widest of walker the
writers
but it was funny you two were sort of
inseparable that night and there were
people I know just in the world that
thought for a while you two were so
close I thought are they a couple yeah
yeah that was something you knew about
right oh we fully knew about it we
played into it but you played into it we
did we were like so on the set we would
kind of you know do the scene and then
we would try and you know just kiss each
other in the middle of the scene and see
if anyone would react and it's Game of
Thrones so incest is so normal that they
were just like more sisters kissing yeah
yeah it was probably the most tame thing
that happened on the show right so you
were you actually wanted to get it out
there that you two were a couple is just
sort of a joke yeah but yeah you know
sometimes you just want to make out the
best friend yeah yeah tell me about it
okay you're feeling it right now
although it's pretty mechanical but a
lot of year both thinking of other
people
[Applause]